o que é arte
quando a gente faz a pergunta
normalmente a primeira coisa que vem à
cabeça de repente uma escultura uma
pintura ou até mesmo grafite mas o que
vem na minha cabeça é escrita pra mim
escrita é uma forma de arte
a escrita pra mim ela se traduz em forma
de arte na literatura principalmente é
uma forma muito intensa de expressão
está muito relacionado com aquele velho
ditado de que a gente só escreve sobre o
que a gente sabe porque também é claro
que a gente não tem como escrever sobre
uma coisa que a gente nunca ouviu falar
mas também quase todo aspecto na vida de
quem escreve falar de alguma maneira é
uma reflexão da própria realidade
o artista transcende a si mesmo em
palavras não é uma inspiração divina não
foi tdlc que viu o condado decidiu
escrever ele nem victor hugo recebeu uma
carta anônima com os amigos do abc nem
gonçalves dias teve uma epifania e de
repente estava a ler minha terra tem
palmeiras onde canta o sabiá
não é assim que funciona sabe é muito
mais intenso é muito mais emocional é
muito é um processo muito incrível
ao mesmo tempo é muito exaustivo mas a
gente não vê isso muitas vezes o nosso
dia a dia a gente não vê a escrita como
essa maneira de arte e acredito eu que
não seja por nenhuma forma de
preconceito nem nada do gênero mas
simplesmente porque é escrita é uma
coisa mas bastante mais complexa quando
tem uma pintura por exemplo ela talito
ver toca ela tem cores é uma forma uma
abstração do teu sentimento que escrever
é se expressar de uma maneira muito mais
literal e muito mais complexa e muito
mais marcante de fato e muitas vezes a
gente leu uma poesia uma crônica ou seja
lá o que for que a gente não presta
muita atenção ou não nos parece tentado
significados porque a gente tá lendo
porque é leitura obrigatória ou porque
apareceu ali ea gente não se importa
muito
mas palavras são provavelmente uma das
maneiras mais intensas de se expressar e
elas têm muita força
palavras podem começar uma revolução
acabar com uma guerra ou simplesmente
ser uma maneira muito profunda de
expressão por exemplo tem um poema do
castro alves que é navio negreiro que é
era um sonho dantesco o tom brady you
que das modernas a vermelha o brilho e
sangue a se banhar tinham de ferro se
instalar de açoite legiões de homens
negros como a noite horrendos a dançar
vocês entendem quando digo que palavras
são intensas que palavras podem causar
uma comoção muito grande e às vezes até
maior do que uma pintura uma escultura e
bom eu gosto muito de escrever eu
acredito que escrever seja essa maneira
intensa e extremamente expressivo de se
mostrar
mas como disse antes a gente não vê isso
muito no nosso dia a dia nem por exemplo
nem mesmo no colégio e no meu ver é
principalmente porque a gente tem a
gente tem aonde literatura ea gente tem
aonde gramática
só que a gente fica muito preso naquele
modelo sala de aula porque as aulas elas
são formatadas de uma maneira pra gente
passar numa prova principalmente
vestibular enem não esteja estabelecendo
eu acho muito importante inclusive mas a
própria dissertação quando foi a última
vez que a gente escreveu uma história
que a gente escrever uma poesia agora a
proposta de intervenção é como a gente
vai mudar a sociedade com aquele texto
que vai nos fazer passar na universidade
e claro é muito importante a gente
aprender isso
mas aí a forma artística acaba se
perdendo um pouco e envolve um pouco
mais de interpretação para usar aquilo
porque se a literatura tem gramática e
tenho a cabeça eu digo isso tem que
fazer juntar para ter um texto para
conseguir inscrever para conseguir se
expressar
a escrita é uma forma de arte tão válida
quanto qualquer outra uma poesia é tão
válida quanto uma tela quanto uma
pintura quanto grafite
quanto mais cultura
e acredito eu que a melhor maneira de eu
acabar com essa apresentação e dia
simplificar o que eu tô falando é
declamar um texto meu eu tenho uma cola
aqui porque um terço cumprido com pés
delicados chegou no banheiro onde se
permitiu queimar debaixo da água quente
podia sentir a pele caindo de seu corpo
escorrendo por entre seus músculos até
ficar só eles a carne só músculo sangue
sorriam se ver em sua essência a água
mesclada de vermelho mestiça se
enrolando antes de ir embora pelo ralo
brilhante no meio disso thiago leite os
brancos
as manchas vermelhas seriam quase
impossíveis de tirar de entre os
pequenos quadrados brancos delicados
quando a água parou de correr ea toalha
já estava bichado de vermelho foi só
então que a pele voltou devagar mas a
devagar preencher o espaço por entre os
músculos suave mais detestável e é isso
aí obrigado